[Music]
she's gorgeous
you can't possibly marry him Diana he's
basically a stranger cause if you don't
have other options the thing is I just
know this is it
now I've got news oh yeah I'm going to
have a baby
yes news i other hand since i'm
proposing you said yeah
[Music]
Robin breathe you inhale the polio virus
from droplets in the air
the result is you've come to breathe for
yourself we really must leave me it's
rotten we can't have this apparently I
can get me out of here
no one your husband's disability exists
outside a hospital anywhere in the world
[Music]
I just had an idea
it does his breathing for him ever no
stubby you now oh boy
alright so while we puppy or pitiful I
mean definitely Blackie is old dowager's
of tough-as-nails what exactly is it you
want from me
well we want more of these chairs for
people like Robin
no one's ever believed as possible to
live as you do it's Bloody Marys
while we should show them
when I first became paralyzed I wanted
to die
[Music]
but my wife wouldn't let me she told me
I had to live as our son grow up so I
went on living
[Music]
your life is my life oh we could have a
party wouldn't that be an adventure why
do you keep your disabled in prison go
back to your agent and set them free
I've accepted the risk of dying I don't
want to just survive
I want to truly live
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you